[Music]
what's up y'all we've got dana come here
we've got leslie grace from in the
heights there
that's right they're stretching it out
you want to know why because derek is a
legendary dancer and leslie kills it in
her new musical and i'm just well
amazing at everything so it's time for a
game we're calling dance battle double
down
[Music]
get it jeff you know what jesse
i think we're gonna need another person
over here and i pick you from the band
yeah
i want that you know why
do you want to know oh are you going oh
i see
you're going to take your earrings off
too what's happening
take my shoes off too are we coming to
play jesse
yeah all right it's gonna be jesse
it's gonna be
it's gonna be jessie and leslie versus
the winners derek and me
now we just need a host so god are you
there lord hey kelly i was just tending
to my garden you like apples i'm just
playing
how you doing girl how you doing
i am good still a little mad that i'm
not invited in but thanks for helping
with the game so could you tell us how
it works well kelly this is a dance game
so i'm going to read a question and the
answer to that question will be the name
of a dance okay now if you know the
dance be the first to jump up on that
platform and give the answer now if
you're right you'll have a chance to
double down for another point by doing
the dance for my own amusement
now we're going to play in rounds kelly
against jesse and derek against leslie
now if kelly wins
if you win kelly the right side of our
house seats will get a cool prize
but if not the left side will win
okay so let's get kelly and jesse up
there first come on now oh wait it's us
first oh
that's right let's do it listen to the
voice of god now good luck
here is your first question okay
what dance move was pioneered by alfonso
ribeiro on the freshman kelly um what is
the name
the name of the dance name of the dance
it's not unusual
carlton it is the carlton now for double
the points can you do the dance let's
get some music
[Music]
[Applause]
called please all right that's enough
now come on now derek and leslie it's
your turn get up there okay it's me now
here's your question get it
derek you look so sexy in that jacket
let me just tell you
okay here's your question the terminator
r2d2 and wall-e
are examples of what
the robot they are and for double the
points can you do the robot music please
think it's like one of these
[Music]
that robot don't need no oil on those
joints let me tell you kelly and jesse
come on get up there let's go again okay
here's a question
here's a question okay okay four to zero
by the way so let's get it together here
you go thank you here's the question
when something totally unexpected
happens in a movie you would say it's a
plot what
we got now hold up hold on
i'm gonna say it's a dance-off ladies
and gentlemen
we have ourselves a tie so it's a
dance-off
are you ready for my movie
am i freaking out because i'm kind of
remembering how to do this all right so
the dance is called
the twist the twist yeah and maestro
please let's see the twist both y'all
[Music]
i got to say jesse is the winner of the
12th guy
[Applause]
oh there he is derrick and leslie it's
all you come on i'm losing from this is
it we got time for one more here we go
now last question here it is
if some dude is working out very very
hard on a treadmill
what would you call it
you see someone
oh derek
now hold on now this is worth triple by
the way i'm throwing in a wrench here
please derek
is it the running mate it is the running
man
and
for double the points can you do the
running man music please
[Music]
bestie would you like to see my twist
again
that is it here we go that's it that
means kelly and derek are the big
winners along with the right side of the
audience but kelly
i know you and i know you probably want
to give the prize to everybody so just
go ahead
[Music]